taking a turn here to a kind of advisory
for shoppers millions of americans are
holiday shopping competing for the best
deals with a certain tireless shopper
who works 24 7 and i got to say this is
not a fair fight retail experts say a
large share of online buying is now
being done by automated robots bots
software designed to scoop up gigantic
amounts of very popular items and then
resell them to actual people at higher
prices as mark strossman reports the
problem has only gotten worse since the
pandemic began
take sony's ps5 gaming console a hot
item in this second coved christmas
about 500 bucks retail but good luck no
store seems to have one
ask dave kennedy a father of two teenage
boys i've been on marketplace like even
on ebay and that and
the astronomical how much
the lowest i think i've seen is above
9.50 you know it's frustrating
absolutely frustrating you know there's
kids that want it there's adults buying
these things to resell them think of
shoppers shoving each other aside in
stores online that stampede is invisible
grinch bots automated software
relentlessly searching finding snapping
up hot consumer items in nanoseconds
before you can it's not illegal but it's
certainly unethical so not black market
but gray market gray market for sure
we met pam murphy the ceo of imperva a
cyber security company at their
headquarters outside of san francisco
here we've got an example of a bad boss
trying to get through impervious
customers include major retailers they
face a perfect grinchbot storm the
pandemic a surge in online shopping and
america's supply chain crisis they
basically go onto retail sites and they
basically scan the inventory at a rate
often more than once per second and they
effectively buy it up before the average
consumer can the average consumer
doesn't have a chance it doesn't have a
chance causes a lot of frustration it
adds no value to the economy you have
bot operators taking the margin and it
goes into an underground economy so no
it's not it's not a good thing for
society bots don't get tired bots never
sleep and during the pandemic bot
activity and retail sites doubled
that's why online you're seeing more of
this captcha command it's a bot blocker
nobody gets all of them right you're
right it can never be a hundred percent
last month nintendo introduced its
gaming console the switch oled edition
grinchbot activity doubled
last christmas the ps5 was new bot
traffic surged 800 percent
murphy a mother of two looked for one
everywhere i ended up purchasing it at a
multiple of what the street market is
from a very
from a site that i wasn't sure honestly
was genuine how much of a retail did you
end up paying
two to three acts
how did that make you feel
uh frustrated like dave kennedy this
christmas you feel a certain amount of
pressure to deliver absolutely and and
it's a letdown for them when you can't
right i'll keep trying yeah even though
you know what you're up against
sometimes you get lucky
he knows the underground economy he's up
against no ifs ands or bots
for cbs mornings mark strossman san
francisco